the Trump organization says it plans to
appeal a jury verdict finding the
company guilty on 17 criminal charges
including tax fraud it's one of Justice
in a series of Investigations into the
former president's businesses Trump by
the way not personally charged in this
case CBS News legal analyst Ricky
cleeman is here to explain the jury
verdict and what it means for Trump and
his businesses Ricky good morning thank
you for being here people look at the
fine 1.6 million doesn't sound large in
the context of a big company but how
serious are the charges overall or the
convictions I should say well the
convictions uh and the 1.6 million
dollars are very serious indeed first of
all we have to look at the entire
perspective this is the first time that
the dam has been broken we have looked
at civil suits against Donald Trump and
his business dealings as well as
personal civil suits but this is the
first time there is a criminal
conviction of the Trump organization not
of Donald Trump personally but when you
have 17 counts that really show a quick
jury verdict so the evidence had to be
overwhelming to this jury of 15 years of
massive widespread tax fraud in the
culture of the company that is serious
indeed in the beginning some would say
that this is a New York story you think
about Leticia James who's the Attorney
General our district attorney Alan Bragg
you said on this air that Leticia James
is practically daring Alvin Bragg to now
come after Mr Trump before do you think
this now turns a spotlight to him like
what you going to do I I think there is
no doubt about it when I had to go after
Trump personally yes when I had said
Leticia James in her filing of her civil
suit which was massive she gave a
blueprint as the Attorney General of New
York to the district attorney of New
York and they both shared information he
was supposed to be investigating Donald
Trump his children and his companies
having to do with the story of inflating
values for loans deflating values of
properties for taxes Alvin Braggs the
DA's investigation has seemed to stall
it seemed to have died well if if there
was a dare by Leticia James to say hey
Mr Bragg hey D.A brag it's time for you
to look again at this investigation this
conviction in his own office is like the
double there yeah so if you had a case
that died or an investigation that died
it suddenly got resurrected I would
think within the office there's no
question now will this legally have an
impact on Mr Trump or his presidential
run in 2024
there's a difference between legally and
personally okay legally it has
absolutely no effect on his person on
his presidential run doesn't matter and
he of course has denied all of these
charges he will continue to say that
it's a Witch Hunt personally it may
matter a great deal because what you
have is his presiding over a company
that looks like it was a criminal enter
prosecutor said he did play a role right
if they did and they argued it
forcefully in rebuttal because the
defense kept saying he playing no role
and so the prosecutor got to say wait a
minute he knew he was aware even if he
did not directly participate that didn't
there of course the lawyers for Mr Trump
and as well as Donald Trump himself
completely denied that nevertheless if
you run a company that way how are you
going to run a country may say the
independent voter that's the question
first breaking the dam as you point out
makes it serious to be continued it
would seem thank you Ricky always good
to have you here thank you